he wanted to fight and he said I'm not
saying [ __ ] if I can't prove I'm
innocent that I'm gonna die in here
nearly 15 years ago 16 year old Arthur
Carmona was heading over to a friend's
house to play video games when he was
stopped at gunpoint by the police
within seconds like a dozen cars cops
jumping out of the car at gunpoint they
handcuffed Arthur they started bringing
people by and they had him stand up look
to the side
people were nodding no the police had
suspected Arthur of robbing a nearby
juice bar Arthur's mom Ronny Sandoval
later found out about video surveillance
showing the robber wearing a baseball
hat a hat that didn't belong to her son
another cop comes she pulls out of black
Lakers baseball cap and they try to
force it on Arthur and he's you know
like what are you doing that's not my
hat it's a god cops tell them well if
you move we're going to shoot you they
forced the cap on his head and people
start coming by again same thing no no
none of the witnesses ever ID'd Arthur
the one person that ID'd him was the
cashier and he ID'd the Hat next thing
we know they're charging my son with 12
armed robberies every case that we look
at is different but there are common
elements there are things that kind of
that seemed to transcend them Rob
Bourdon of North Western center on
wrongful convictions has helped piece
together the National Registry of
exonerations which documents over a
thousand people who have been exonerated
in the u.s. our great hope for the
registry is providing data that will
lead to that will fortify arguments for
reform the registry was released earlier
this year and has shined a spotlight on
the many systemic problems with the
justice system that leads to wrongful
convictions like flawed eyewitness
testimony that's highlighted in Arthur's
case the number one cause of wrongful
convictions clearly is eyewitness error
we know that we can reduce the number of
erroneous eyewitness identifications if
we vary the process by which
the police conduct lineups instead of
having people stand in a row like you've
seen countless times on television if
you do it first of all with photographs
and you present them sequentially rather
than in an array that eliminates the
tendency to make a relative judgement
that is to pick the person in the group
who most resembles the perpetrator if
the perpetrator doesn't happen to be
there another huge problem is false
confessions which factor into roughly
half of the cases that warden has looked
at in Illinois alone this is the single
factor that that people have the hardest
time wrapping their mind around it's
possible for the police literally to
brainwash an individual into accepting
the proposition that he or she might
have committed this crime and blacked it
out of their mind and then they will
start trying to get you to
hypothetically speculate on how the
crime might have occurred and the
statements you make are then construed
as a confession the registry includes
cases dating back to 1989 when DNA was
first successfully used as evidence in
an exoneration a lot of people say think
that DNA is some kind of a panacea that
now that we have DNA we'll have well
this solves the wrongful conviction
problem unfortunately it doesn't DNA is
available in only a tiny minority of all
criminal convictions in Arthur's case
had DNA that could have exonerated him
from day one but it was never used
during his trial the person when he was
casing that the juice bar he went in and
he ordered a juice the juice Cup so they
had his saliva and DNA in that cup we
didn't know about it so they would have
known from the get-go from the very
beginning if they would have run that
DNA they would have known it was an
Arthur how could the police be so
negligent was it malice corruption one
common element that occurs in a lot of
cases in which there have been wrongful
convictions is a phenomena we call
tunnel vision that is that some police
officer some detective gets a theory of
the crime and finds some evidence to
support that
theory and then as the investigation
progresses anything else that comes to
light that can possibly be construed as
cooperating that is so construed and
anything that comes to light that
doesn't fit is given short shrift or
just basically ignored and it's not a
matter of guilt or innocence it's a
matter of can I get a conviction or not
so nobody's really taking a look at the
evidence at the case itself
so once the DA starts that case whether
they're right or wrong they're not going
to stop
tunnel vision isn't an easy problem to
fix but forcing detectives officers and
other officials involved to take
responsibility for misconduct might be a
start
a lot of the statements that were made
afterwards basically said that we didn't
do anything wrong the jury wrongfully
convicted him in fact there's a certain
tool the district attorney has that lets
an innocent person out of prison but
also strips the justice system of
responsibility for any wrongdoing the DA
offered to let him go if he signed a
stipulation and the the stipulation in
short basically said I promise not to
sue the city the two cities the police
departments and in exchange I'll get my
freedom he didn't want to sign it the US
Supreme Court has condoned that
procedure it's called an Alford plea and
it's really kind of a form of torture
you you've just fought for years for to
overturn your case the prosecution is
basically dangling a carrot in front of
you that look here's the key to your
cell you can walk out today all you have
to do is enter you know sign this piece
of paper if you don't sign it we're
gonna take you back to trial and who
knows we convicted you once without any
evidence maybe we'll do it again he
wanted to fight and he said I'm not
saying [ __ ] if I can't prove I'm
innocent that I'm gonna die in here
well me selfish you know mother I wanted
my son I wrote a letter a note and I
said sign the paper
just get out so
he ended up signing it he was not
officially exonerated that's when I
started to realize the damage I did
because he needed to be exonerated you
know it's very difficult to exonerate
someone you know you find that once
you're convicted of the crime the
evidence that it takes to exonerate you
is just got to be far greater than the
evidence that it took to convict you in
the first place
no compensation the felonies followed
him with Arthur finally out of prison
Ronny was looking forward to making up
for lost time with her son but their
time was cut short when Arthur was
killed in an unrelated hit and run not
long after getting out his innocence was
never legally recognized and he was
never truly freed I'm disgusted with
what they did to my son it was as simple
as him walking out the door to go play
video games and he stepped into the
twilight zone and it followed him for
all the days of his life exposing these
and justices as wardens greatest hope
for reform and his team will continue to
plunge into the cases of the countless
more wrongfully convicted still behind
bars